got a question for Scarlett obviously
your character could have easily just
been kind of written off as the sexy one
of the team how important is it that how
important is it for you that she's
actually smart as well as hot and are
you livid that there's not a black widow
film yet how important is that she's
really intelligent as well as being sexy
and are you angry that there's not a
black widow film in the works yet yes I
don't know how to answer that
she's few yeah I think I'm I think one
of the really the I think one of the
qualities in the widow that I that I
love and I'm interested in is that she
you know is she's you know when faced
with this kind of she's kind of put in
the work and she's you know she I feel
like she's at a place where she's able
to you know kind of maybe do something
for herself and and and make this you
know kind of maybe even have a
relationship with somebody maybe even
open up in that way there's this kind of
greater calling this this that that's
that's pulling her and she very
selflessly chooses that and it's it's
heroic in a big way in a small way um
you know she's she's really kind of in
herself which is interesting because she
also plays a character that's very I
mean she also actually does breaker
she's very kind of slippery fish for her
job but when you get her Natasha she's
in herself which is kind of cool
and she's in her sexy self and yeah a
black widow movie that would be cool you
know I'm always happy to put the cat
suit back on and get in front of all
those mirrors just like Robert I'm an
actor so you know from your lips to
Marvel's big big pocketed ears
you